hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer question from
one of my youtube viewers coach Keller
Coleman who we've talked about before I
think and he's launched a new site is
relaunching his book and wanted my
advice on his website and I thought it'd
be a lot easier to do this as a
screencast you can see the website along
with me instead of just seeing me on
camera so let's click on his site and
see what's happening here so this is a
site he's got a video here it looks from
the site that he's all about helping
people take action so yes massive action
max results let's make things happen
greatness within you I don't know about
the kind of coffee stain here but you
know it's all about getting actions put
your goals on the fast track so kind of
get understanding what he is talks about
the value here you're getting results
that you've been looking for this last
sentence bothered me a little bit so it
says coach Keller says individuals
organizations and small businesses
change their thinking using basic
problem solving approaches which
enhances their performance and increases
the results so it's that's probably what
you do but it's kind of boring so try to
get a little bit more into the details
of how you can help so instead of saying
that you use basic problem solving
approaches I talk a little bit about the
pain points that you help solve here and
how you go about doing it this is kind
of blanket statement and enhances of
performance increases the results
everybody says that I guess that's the
point so you want to try to have
something that stands out that makes it
unique and by watching your videos and
read any book you know that that you're
a unique guy you're not kind of just see
everybody guys so you're not the
everyday business coach so you want to
you know show a little bit more about
how you're different and change that
around and really tap into what makes
you you scrolling a little bit more here
it says therefore ways that you can help
discover how to make a plan make it
happen by reading your books and in
number three is kind of the same
investing your personal professional
success by reading your books so you
know maybe that's combined into one
the taking of two points of them on the
right side here it says you can register
to win to receive a free report and get
an instant access and if you click here
I'll just load a new tab it actually
just sends you right to this PDF so you
can see the link here at the bottom left
of the screen it says right to a PDF
file so i didn't have to actually
register that you said here to get
access to it i can just kind of load it
up in this new file so it's it's still
loading but you know there's a file so i
want to make sure that there's a
registration page there behind it if if
you want people to register or you can
just be given that thing away for free
scrolling down here on the right side it
looks a little gimmicky you see this a
lot with the internet marketing type of
products register right now you know red
arrows and all that so it might you know
do you mean or decrease the value a
little bit for people coming to my
thinks a little bit of a scam which
which is obviously not so says you want
a free gift when I click through it says
you can win a free ipad 2 if you can
avoid ipad actually i would make that a
lot more noticeable on the site say you
give them an ipad instead of a free gift
which people might think is a key
product or something that might not have
a lot of value so definitely put that
front center if you're going to be
giving away an ipad 2 as i scroll down
here so you know i'm somebody hopefully
your hope you're finding people come to
the website who need help with their
goals i see you something to help them
out I'd want to see content that then
motivates me to want to see you as an
expert to contact you or things that are
going to inspire me to want to take
action on my goals whether I end up
hiring you right now or you know
sometime in the future so as I scroll
down beyond your know how you can help
me get down to things here like joke of
the day you know it's it's it's okay but
it doesn't really help inspire me to
want to go after and shoot for my goals
and maybe this is just what happens to
be on your site today but I try to make
your post a little bit more
inspirational motivating want me to go
out and reach my goals
scrolling down so happy spring your
privacy is valued into the wind and
there's this arrow that kind of points
off somewhere so not really inspiring me
right so I just try to shape up the
content a little bit to focus on maybe
if you're real launching the book what's
in the book and what are some of the
inspirational things that you have to
share or your story or how you help
people it'd be great to see some
testimonials of people who've gone
through your process or read your book
and really like it those are all be
great things I've on here to have a
consistent message your people who are
visiting your site instead of here we're
kind of bounces around people aren't
quite sure what to do next scrolling
down here it see this a little bit of a
typo here copyright is not how WR ite
its righ T so that's a quick change and
I'm sure your guys here can make make an
update on and then one last thing i
guess if i look at the top if i go to
your store as that loads i noticed that
you might want to do a little bit of
work on the design so it's great here
you any of your product a little bit
about yourself the book it's great but
then it is ginormous buy now button
that's all pixelated so you might want
to get a bigger buy now button or you'll
design your own or keep it the original
size so it's not as pixelated it just
makes it look a little bit cheap or if
you had a proper design you can pick
them up for free or low-cost just to get
that looking a little bit better so when
people come to your site they have
confidence that this is a quality book
or ebook that they should invest the
money in as well as investor times
actually read it and start taking action
on results on the things you say that so
you're going to help me do so hopefully
that helps for everybody watching i'd
love to hear what you have to think if
you go to keller coleman calm and check
it out feel free to leave some comments
below it be great to hear what you have
to think about it and if you like the
video i always appreciate seeing those
thumbs ups come in there if you have
another question feel free to leave in
the comments below so make sure you take
action please it's always great than I
thank you for your support so thank you
for watching this video and
you on the next episode
you
you